hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the don't laugh challenge
we got Bob wait and Tyler and Ethan I
want you to forgive me I wasn't gonna
forget you've got Bob wait and Tyler and
that's it nobody yell babies over there
hi Garbo
oh you don't write positivity she's not
laughing we're either will you be yeah
that's right this is the don't laugh
challenge which is true to its name
we're not going to laugh so weights
going to go first because he's like a
hardest to make laugh probably of all of
us so we're going to attempt to make him
laugh we've got a new selection of props
here's a glorious insert of all of our
props with angelic choir music intro
anime explosions why also here's an
elaborate scoreboard for the exact times
and dates of with which people laugh
spoiler alert here's the end result
anyway
it's late we are tired we just ate a lot
of chicken and dumplings so if we laugh
we're probably gonna vomit
if laugh at all this is the least funny
part of our entire lives here we go we
have two minutes we're gonna make it two
full minutes too long minutes then you
have to not laugh you thinking about
dead people what's up my cracking crew
lock I knew you're good lever [ __ ]
I'm Ethan this is correct
game plays that's why I wanna play some
happy wheels for all you guys I love
except the guy
y'all I'm a pirate top me under your
legs I'm Jack said you're good ah
this feels good oh my god hello
everybody I'm old markiplier and we're
gonna play some amnesia custom stories
today I have a fake laugh yeah let's go
get them all you guys
what a reaction huh alright alright
goodbye then
that's an Elvis is it's little bit about
that Mel look I'm not going to touch you
smack
well let's suck the acid I wore a second
set hose one all right fine [ __ ] your
outing I'm gonna go spit your water out
look at my smaller than four crews okay
ready
two minutes on the timer after you Oh
break it was one of my breaking ground
crank crank that's not the intro at all
hi I'm Craig gameplays before I dyed my
hair to copy all the other youtubers
general why is my channel still dying
even though I'm so desperate oh boy I
keep the seasons little vision this
jumped in for me oh no God this is the
human vagina also known as the earth
watch as the ovum is penetrated over and
over and over again
ovulation has begun when the rotating
action engages like I was laughing at me
sit there laughing oh my ally into it
are you unfunny bastards gonna try to
make me laugh no
[Music]
it's me
Lord minions hey look Lord minion 777
from high school my head [ __ ] hair
hey look it's me Lord minion 777 are you
[ __ ] why is that funny
are you were saying that up everyone I'm
Lord minute I'm looking for additions
read you want starting tagger oh there's
another hilarious reference to something
you did in the past marching band you
were screwed a pop idol guard you were
part of the Royal Guard just wins you
got their lawyers solids what what are
you really just a little bit oh man the
piece mirror is the one ready can you
tell the difference
two creatures excuse me I'd like to sing
a song I am special
oh my girth II coq au coeur the simpler
times when everyone just made fun of
your mom change is a good one too much
yes get ready to make me laugh well it's
for work let's go in front of them and
you draw a caricature yeah yeah good
longer wait even look at that longer
longer yeah Berthier okay can you draw
him say what's up my crazy crew what's
that my this looks like you I got you a
sketch mark cuz I remember way back
interesting how mark is always wanted a
penis no with that did do you think that
would fit in your tight pants you want
to take a picture with me
my heart was it even departed okay Wow
someone for okay night it came out the
leagues wait wait wait something oh my
god mom you Jansen do not be yeah it's
funny your fits on wait no this I'm not
a lot of times me already Sparrow a ride
it add some projectile tea smells so bad
I love she goes party you know judge did
you say it's me four million 777 change
its me markiplier change what on my
crazy boy you guys don't even need to
plans click click check I have severe
acne and there's nothing that I can do
about it it's my body and I can't help
it I take medication but it doesn't go
away I'm tired of your acne just [ __ ] me
please I'm Dez apply ya dick on my mind
that sucks
it's official we're not funny Oh
[Music]
it's okay oh no it's okay either it's
okay okay bend over you [ __ ] robot
they called a butyl Oh eyes right in
that bird I've seen Turner it's me
markiplier change it's me mark upon the
lady you'd be war Jay drivers who look
wait please it's me when Ethan wait
Lanai sure did at my tits I hold it
together for so long with interested
like spreading and smiling with them I'm
markiplier I raise hundreds of thousands
of dollars for charity
tell me like to do charity hey crazy
cranks I'm grandma I boobs the little of
the shootin videos with grandma I'm your
grandma we all make it alone people long
ago decided is that we their society
must what is up my cranky crew ha ha the
carpet does match the drapes the carpet
does match the drapes
all right ready all right oh I'm
all-star quarterback Tom Brady all right
it's important that I hold both what's
up bobbleheads did you back up wait
yeah wait yeah yeah we good my crazy
won't be a baby do you want to go we're
going
yeah hip hip oh we start oh okay all
right Morgan I have a thing all right
mark let's do a simulation of YouTube
yeah okay this is a handful of attention
I'm a viewer is it bling
happy wheels video oh I'm good for like
two weeks me great game why do we keep
mark oh I'm in second challenges we
gotta make Bob laughs we have to make
foam ask you we have to I'm your old
college roommate
these are wrist braces cuz more crafts
ruin my life that's just sad change Oh
God all right combing the comedy out
[ __ ]
laughs please I'm desperate change oh I
don't like this change
so that was the don't laugh challenge
with Bob wait Tyler Ethan and myself Amy
Amy was also here hi chica was also part
of this really cheap [ __ ] out oh
there's all that remains these these are
always a time and a testament to the
limit to which you will test friendship
and a realization of how hollow an empty
we actually are as people so thanks for
not laughing with us and as always we'll
see you in the next review bye bye